Speaker 1: We have been covering
this completely outrageous
revelation about Mark Milley, the general
having to take preventive measures after
Trump lost to Joe Biden in November of twenty
twenty and after the Trump riots because he was
worried that Donald Trump might consider launching
nukes, including possibly against China. Trump
once merely charged with treason, as best Levin
writes in Vanity Fair for making him look stupid,
a reaction keeping in line with Trump's famously
thick skin. This is a very much worth reading
article. Best writing sometime. Something you
may have gleaned is Trump doesn't take criticism,
constructive, real or imagined very well.
One major example of his paper thin skin
is his reaction to the American people denying
him a second term in office, which resulted in
him inciting a violent mob to attack the U.S.
Capitol. Naturally, it is in no way surprising
his reaction to the news that Mark Milley took
steps to stop him from starting a war with China
and a nuclear war with any number of
countries was characteristic of Trump, i.e.
bat as crazy with a string of terrifying run
on sentences to boot. Donald Trump put out a
statement in response to this saying, If the story
of a dumbass General Mark Milley, the same failed
leader who engineered the worst withdrawal from
a country Afghanistan in U.S. history, remember,
that was Trump's withdrawal, leaving behind many
dead and wounded soldiers, many American citizens,
and 85 billion dollars worth of the newest and
most sophisticated military equipment in the
world. And our country's reputation is true.
Then I assume he would be tried for treason
and that he would have been dealing with his
Chinese counterpart behind the president's
back and telling China he would be giving them
notification of an attack. Can't do that. Trump
going on to say the good news is the story is fake
news concocted by a weak and ineffective general,
together with two authors who I refused to give
an interview to because they write fiction.
This is a run on sentence string of insanity. And
here was Trump as a reminder on Newsmax making
similar claims. This is a former President Fox.
Speaker 3: So first of all, if it is actually
true, which is hard to believe that he would have
called China and China things and was willing to
advise them of an attack or in advance of
an attack, that's treason. And I would think
I've had so many calls today saying that's
treason, number one. And number two, it's
totally ridiculous. I never thought of it. You
were there. You were you knew what was happening
in the White House. You have plenty of friends.
You never heard the word China mentioned in a
thing like this. You heard a lot of anger.
Speaker 1: So remember, he's referring, of course,
to Sean Spicer saying you were at the White
House. Actually, Spicer was long gone by the
time all of this stuff was going on. That's of
no meaning. But multiple times now, Trump says
treason. He wants the general charged with
treason. The correct assessment of this is
even if ultimately, if merely, let's imagine Trump
tried to launch nukes. If initially Meely tried
to prevent that in some way, Trump could fire
Meely and eventually replace him with someone
who would allow the nukes to be fired. That's the
reality. Ultimately, Meely could not have actually
prevented this, but merely out of a responsibility
to the United States and the world identified such
an unusual danger to the United States and
the world in Trump in these deranged final
13 days. Right. We're talking about the period
between January eight when Meely had this meeting
with other military officials and Trump leaving
office. That's the period we're talking about,
that Meely had to do something completely
different than what former chairman of the
Joint Chiefs have had to do. That's the real
story. And of course, there is no treason here.
Trump is completely unhinged. It shouldn't
surprise us. And it's another reminder of
we should be as disastrous as the presidency
was. We should be glad that it wasn't even worse,
given what Trump's tendencies were as
further revealed. That's the takeaway.
Not that Mark Milley is a traitor.
Quite the opposite, in fact.